Today, I want to talk about reading,
which I consider to be the killer app.
It is the killer app for so many things,
for education, for communicating with
people, for connecting with people
in history, people in different
countries, and for acquiring languages.
So, today I want to give you my six tips
on powering up your reading capability,
both for language learning and in general.
First tip, read a lot.
There is no shortcut.
People who read a lot become good readers.
They also become more proficient
in the languages they're learning.
They become better writers
in their own language.
Read a lot.
Recently I was interested
in the subject of reading.
So I Googled different podcasts
on reading, on literacy,
in different languages.
Along the way, I discovered this
series of lectures from France,
from the Collège de France.
And there they described, I think, in
very simple terms, what reading is.
Reading basically piggybacks on the
areas of the brain that process.
Audio meaning sounds come into the
brain and a certain area and the sounds
become meaning as we become familiar
or are familiar with the language.
And reading has a separate entry port.
Initially you go to the sort
of sound area of the brain to
follow the chain down to meaning.
And as we become more proficient
readers, we can actually bypass
that and go straight to meaning
at least some of the time.
Now, not all languages are equal.
Some languages are more,
call it transparent.
The relationship between the
letters and the sound is more
consistent than in other languages.
However, the areas in the brain
that are activated are all the same.
And in all cases, the sort of simple
view of reading, which is what I
described, is a process of self education.
The more we read, the more we
become familiar with what the
letters represent, the better we do.
And so if we read a book
like Harry Potter and
The Sorcerer's Stone, we have 76, 000
opportunities to refine and confirm
our understanding of how the writing
system connects to sound and then to
meaning, a magic thing that mankind
didn't have for most of history.
Now, the educators were not content
with the simple view of reading, this
sort of magic self educating process.
And so they came up with
additional sort of details.
One was this Scarborough's Rope,
which introduces the importance of
comprehension, the importance of prior
knowledge, the importance of vocabulary.
But all of those things come
automatically if we do enough reading.
And listening, which I will get to.
That's why now I come to my point.
Number two, don't worry too
much about comprehension.
If you are reading and you understand 60,
70%, you are still practicing reading.
You are encountering the
words in different contexts.
The things that you don't understand
now, you may understand later just
through the process of reading.
And I always like to quote Rubem
Alves, the great Brazilian educator,
who says nothing disrupts the pleasure
of reading as much as being asked
questions about what we are reading.
If we follow rule number one and
read enough, we will eventually
understand more and more.
And I will get to the issue of people
with reading difficulties like dyslexia.
So don't fuss about what
you don't understand now.
What matters is how much
will you understand later on.
Number three.
Listen, it's all input, reading, listening
is part of the same process, follows the
same parts of our brain, except that the
reading comes through a different port.
So you need to take
advantage of listening.
I find that if I'm reading something
that's difficult in another
language, if I can hear it first.
Then I have a bit of a headstart.
I have some sense of what
the reading is about.
Imperfect, you know, 20%.
I even got a bit of a rhythm,
some momentum on reading.
All of this helps me to read.
After having read something, if I
then listen to it again, it helps to
reinforce it because the words that we
notice while listening are also words
that we will notice better when reading.
So we should always
incorporate audio with text.
That's the way LingQ is built.
That's my basic principle
of language learning.
I always have audio and text until
I'm quite advanced in the language.
Now, in today's day and
age, we have text to speech.
So even while reading, if I'm not sure
how something is pronounced, I can
use text to speech so I can hear it.
So that's another example of how we use...
Use audio in conjunction with reading.
This has never been easier.
We have automatic intelligence.
So even if you bring in a text which
has no audio, you can convert it to
audio using artificial intelligence.
So use audio to accelerate the
process of learning through.
Input and of connecting the
code, the letter code to the,
uh, sound and the meaning.
So the third thing is use audio.
The fourth thing is very context, read
online, read on paper, read online
in order to take advantage of online
dictionaries, the audio functions that
are available online, the ability to find
material online, I can read on paper.
And I think it's a good
idea to read on paper.
In addition to reading online, but
I find it at my current stage in
Arabic and Persian too difficult.
On the other hand, in other languages,
Romanian, even Greek, Russian,
Ukrainian, I can read paper books.
And I like to vary that content online
and paper, even books in English.
For example, the professor whom
I mentioned at the beginning,
Stanislas Duen, I saw him online,
but I also bought the book.
I've mentioned before Daniel
Willingham, Outsmart Your Brain,
but I also ended up buying the book.
So I think it's important.
In reading to use the advantages of online
learning, but it's also a good thing to
read paper books and it's a good thing
to read a variety of sources on the
same subject rather than trying to beat
yourself up in trying to remember this
word or trying to remember this date.
If you read two or three different books
on the same subject, you will acquire that
greater knowledge of the subject matter
that will improve your comprehension.
And comprehension is something that
builds gradually and something that
personally, I don't like being tested
on using comprehension questions.
Number five is use the functionality
that's available in different
language learning apps like LingQ.
So at LingQ, I very much recommend.
Sentence view, because there are
always sentences that we didn't quite
understand, even if we know all the words.
And I don't like going to sentence
view for every sentence in a text,
but I do go for those sentences
where I'm having a little difficulty.
I can group certain words
together as phrases.
Some words belong with other words
and it's not obvious the first time.
But if I go back into
sentence view, I look at it.
I can save a phrase.
I can also do that little exercise
where the sentence gets scrambled and
I have to put it back together again.
And I've always said this, you
know, you need both the top down
learning and the bottom up learning.
You need the big picture and the details.
And the sentence view
is a great place to go.
To get at the details, the DNA of the
language, and that gives you more sort
of ammunition as you charge forward in
your big picture, listening and reading.
And finally, number six, I said, I would
talk a bit about dyslexia through these
different podcasts that I listened to.
I became aware of a person called
Cliff Weitzman, who developed
a software called Speechify,
which enables you to convert any.
Text into audio that's not so unique
nowadays, and he can then increase
the speed two times, three times.
And the reason he did that was because
he was dyslexic and he found that
listening to audio at two or three times
the speed helped him cure his dyslexia.
Can't vouch for that.
I don't know whether it's true or not,
but I have been practicing that at LingQ.
So I can go to the, what we
call the karaoke mode and
crank it up to 1.5
times, two times, and training
yourself to follow along and to
read at that speed does wonders.
You actually have more of a bird's
eye view, it seems to me, of the text.
As you are listening to the new words come
at you rather quickly, you're able to kind
of remember what you just heard earlier.
It's just a different experience.
Now, speed listening to a whole audio
book, you're going to miss a lot.
So that's not the suggestion.
The suggestion I'm making here is
experiment with different speeds of
listening to increase your ability
to process the language, not because
while you're listening at double the
speed, you're going to understand more.
You'll probably understand less, but I
find that when I go back to listening at
a normal speed, and even in terms of the
impact on my reading, it's beneficial,
so it's a bit like this fart leg.
run for runners, where they experiment
with sprinting and then running at more
of a jogging pace and then sprinting.
And apparently this builds
up your aerobic capacity.
So my sixth and final suggestion
or tip is play with the speed of
listening as it connects the reading.
Build up your capability and reading
increase your enjoyment of reading.
And I think you will find
benefits, not only in language
learning, but in life in general.
And I'll leave you with.
Two videos that I did on the
subject of reading and literacy some
while ago, and you'll see that my
perspective has changed somewhat.
Thanks for listening.